at EA when I was making Dead Space
they're like hey we're gonna now that we
see how good it is we're going to give
you some extra money to to make a scare
system if they aren't scared in like 10
minutes and we'll have something come
out and scare them and I'm like that is
the exact opposite of what I want that
is Glenn Schofield best known for
directing the 2008 sci-fi horror Dead
Space ahead of the release of the
Callisto protocol the first game from
his new studio Striking Distance we sat
down with Glenn to talk about his horror
influences and how he hopes his new game
will get inside the head of even the
most seasoned horror fan
[Music]
from its very first trailer the Callisto
protocol Drew understandable comparisons
to Dead Space released back in 2008 Dead
Space drew a claim for its immersive
sci-fi atmosphere and its unrestrained
graphic violence
in the Years following its launch Dead
Space has proven to be a big influence
on the survival horror genre and it has
to be said on the Callisto protocol
itself but despite the unfortunate
timing of EA's own Dead Space remake
launching in a few months time Glenn
insists he wasn't out to compete with
his previous title I wasn't looking to
outdo uh dead space I didn't set out to
make it on more brutal in one of this or
that I was just like I'm gonna make
something different and so there's more
Story the combat has evolved quite a bit
it wasn't a matter of like make
something scarier or this or that it's
just make something different than Dead
Space to give fans something that I
hoped that they wanted it feels like
since Dead Space came out like the the
horror genre has grown I hadn't really
seen a great sci-fi horror game in a
long time
whether or no Striking Distance has been
successful in distancing the two games
is Up For Debate both games feature a
relatively ill-equipped protagonist
exploring a dark and dangerous sci-fi
facility filled with mutated humans to
most people's eyes the differences are
going to be pretty subtle however it
seems this is as much a reflection of
Glenn's personal horror tastes and real
life influences as it is a director
sticking with an established formula and
first a Sci-Fi guy and then I started
getting into uh horror and sci-fi horror
I you know I can remember Pinhead and
you know Clyde Barker's stuff John
Carpenter's a thing of course Halloween
and I've started getting into foreign
stuff over the years Argento in Italy to
Mikey and Japan in the US it's getting
more brutal
um with people like Rob Zombie getting
into it even ones that are more subtle
like life which is a great sci-fi horror
and even a quiet place I like monsters
that come from humans even even the
weird ones in ours you'll see them they
have human teeth or they'll have a spine
or something and that's because to me
the most brutal thing you can come
across is a human like Jeffrey Dahmer or
Ed gain or any of these guys it's just
crazy so take someone like Dahmer and
you're like that is not a normal human
the brutality is just beyond what you
can think about I always want that sort
of in the back your head is like is this
guy as intelligent as me like that's a
scary monster
though Glenn references real-life serial
killers it's clear that the monsters
found in Dead Space in the Callisto
protocol are drawn from the long Cannon
of grizzly Creations found in body
horror body horror is a sub-genre of
horror obsessed with deforming and
defining the body in the most graphic
and gratuitous ways possible think of
Seth brundle's hideous transformation in
the fly French new extreme Cinema films
like Martyrs or even traditional zombie
films which Revel in showing you the
rotting decaying flesh of their monsters
in visceral detail in his book about the
horror genre dance Macabre Stephen King
memorably broke horror fiction down to
three levels Terror horror and grossout
according to King Terra is the finest
emotion in horror playing on the
viewer's imagination and horror relies
on a combination of both imagination and
imagery that invites a physical reaction
by showing something which is physically
wrong like a giant spider but gross out
horror horror that plays on feelings of
revulsion and disgust a aims to make the
audience or the player physically react
or recoil to what they see by being as
revolting and transgressive as possible
in some ways body horror is this gross
out part of the genre operating on its
most base psychological level and it can
be brutally effective so much so that
Stephen King claims to Only Resort to it
when Terror and horror fail him stating
if I find I cannot terrify them I will
try to horrify and if I cannot horrify
I'll go for the gross out I'm not proud
one thing that's pretty clear from the
Callisto protocol is that Glenn
Schofield is not proud either it is
absolute horror maximalism
from the shrieking score that erupts
during jump scares to the over-the-top
death animations visited upon Paul Jacob
that will no doubt be cut into YouTube
compilations for anyone wishing to
satisfy that gross out itch however
another thing that's pretty clear is
that Glenn is a die-hard horror fan and
he knows what fans will be expecting
from a game like the Callisto protocol
as such Striking Distance has gone to
some length to ensure the game remains
surprising and scary even for people who
know their horror games inside out
so to speak
one of the ways they hope to achieve
this is through something they call
horror engineering a philosophy where
they hope to combine elements of
brutality atmosphere tension
helplessness and Humanity into every
encounter there's a lot of thought
behind it we make sure that those five
big uh temples are are within the game
and that we're using them but the
engineering is also because I believe
that the best video games setups and
things like that are at the intersection
of art design and Technology when the
three of them kind of hit you know like
in a monster or a scare right that's
when video games are at their best
through this horror engineering Striking
Distance hopes to ensure that Callisto
remains unpredictable to every player
resisting the well-worn patterns and
rhythms of survival horror that many of
us are so familiar with in essence Glenn
Schofield hopes that as a die-hard
horror fan he's in the perfect position
to pull the rug out from other horror
veterans when it comes to putting setups
together there are no rules the
setup itself may be that harder
engineering but where it happens and how
it happens is from the gut right you
know I had someone say at EA when I was
making Dead Space they're like hey we're
gonna now that we see how good it is
we're going to give you some extra money
to to make a scare system if they aren't
scared in like 10 minutes and we'll have
something come out and scare them I'm
like that is the exact opposite of what
I want I want to scare you and then you
go
all right and then I give you five
minutes and we scare you again or I'm
gonna scare you and two seconds later
I'm gonna get you again because you'll
never think that we'll do it and then
once you know we're gonna mess with you
now we got you and that's why we do
things like at the beginning of the game
we might scare you out a door or do
something in an elevator right because
then you're always going to be like you
know hyper Vigilant
if you're not a horror fan being
confronted with a game where so much
effort is being put into creating as
scary an experience as possible might
sound like a total nightmare but as
we've covered previously on Mind Games
some studies suggest that experiencing
recreational fear through horror media
has benefits for developing your skills
in emotional regulation if you're like
me and you love horror that theoretical
benefit you get from horror might sound
familiar oh I think it's like a roller
coaster ride I think they uh they like
that adrenaline rush you know that
anticipation and then like uh you know
it's coming but you don't know exactly
when when you're gonna hit that Crest
you don't really go through scares for
10 hours in life right and this is just
a chance to tap into a much different
set of emotions when I'm about to watch
a movie a scary movie there's some days
I'm like no not tonight actually you
know because sometimes horror you got to
get into it right I think that's the way
with uh with the game like that and with
this one we are really trying to immerse
you in it like we spend so much time
energy money on that main character and
the other characters so that the eyes
are right so the teeth are right so they
there's nothing to take you out of the
situation you're in that's why we spent
so much time on the the backgrounds to
try and just make you feel like you're
there if you're a horror veteran the
Callisto protocol may prove to be a
useful experience in that it's a game
aiming to undermine the expectations of
those very players who think they know
exactly what awaits them it's a love
letter to the genre and to those players
who enjoy being scared just make sure
you've got a strong stomach
ah
roller coasters
yeah
um and let me tell you sometimes a jump
scare will get me what I'm not expecting
it
um you know I love it when the camera's
over there
and I'm like okay where are they gonna
show it and then it gets me from
someplace else
um that that kind of scares me